so uh good evening everyone from india
i'm professor dr sima patnagar assistant
director at amity institute of
biotechnology and today i am here to
talk about
folate receptor a rational therapeutic
target for cancer treatment this is the
area in which i am working and i will
also be speaking a bit about the
programs at amity
as per the session schedule
so cancer as we know is becoming a
global
epidemic and
we are seeing more and more cancer cases
uh it is estimated that
one in five people will be
suffering from cancer in coming years
and this includes one in eight men and
one in eight females will also succumb
to the disease so this is something
really alarming and something that
requires immediate attention
and
so so
that is what is the focus of my talk
today
we are also seeing that
in middle and
medium and low income countries
there will be a steep rise in the cancer
cases
as predicted by by 2040
as compared to the countries where
already there are more cases but in in
future we will see more cases in
countries which are of low and medium
income
so india falls in that category and
that's why this is a matter of concern
to everyone
[Music]
if we talk of the cancer mortality the
situation is
[Music]
alarming as well
so if you see the gender divide
males and females equally are
equally prone to the disease and we are
seeing a high mortality of the disease
both in males and females
and india has a high mortality rate
so historically if we look at
the drugs or the chemotherapeutic agents
which are which were available
for treatment of cancer we see that uh
the first attempts to look at
chemotherapeutic agents started
somewhere in the late 1940s
and truly the decade between 1960 to
1970 can be called as the decade of
adjuvant chemotherapy where a number of
agents were
not only discovered but they were also
tested and
many of them were from plant sources and
they are still in use today however
they have a number of drawbacks and that
is the reason for the
growing concern about
how we can improve the quality of life
of individuals and how we can prevent
the disease or if not preventable at
least treat them and
improve the quality of life of cancer
patients
the last 20 years from the year 2000
has seen a large number of small
molecules that are coming up for
targeted cancer therapy there are a
number of targets
that have been explored and small
molecules that target these
receptors
or pathways in
for cancer
have shown a lot of promise however
if we look
in terms of the experience of patients
we don't see much
improvement and according to the world
world health organization
every year in india at least 10
10 lakh individuals
suffer from the disease and the spending
in a cancer
suffering
household is at least 36 to 44
higher than as compared to households of
similar demographics even the cost of
treatment has gone up so what is really
wrong are we not having drugs or if you
are having drugs then why are we not
able to reduce the cost and what is the
way to improve the quality of life of
individuals who
suffer from the disease so this is uh
something that
that needs to be looked into
so all this has given
initially there was the focus was on
traditional medicine which included
radiation chemotherapy and surgery but
now this has given way to more targeted
therapies the involvement of genetics of
individuals and also immunotherapy
for treatment of the disease
[Music]
so also our group
at amity is involved in study of the
folate receptor and we are looking into
new drug delivery options uh how we can
deliver low concentration of the drug to
the cancer cells in a targeted way and
the folate receptor appears as a very
attractive target
for cancer drug delivery the reason
being that first of all it has been
newly identified and
there are three isoforms of the folate
receptor the folate receptor alpha beta
and gamma however the folate receptor
alpha
has uh has seen a lot of success and
promising therapeutic target in a
variety of cancers
non-malignant tissues
express very limited amount of folate
receptor alpha whereas
the
the
malignant tissues and especially solid
tumors uh the ovarian cancer kidney lung
brain
breast cancer
lung cancer and you name it all these
have
over expression of um the folate
receptor
also what is important is that folate
the folate receptor alpha has high
affinity for folic acid and conjugates
of folic acid can be considered as good
um
opportunities to target the cancer cells
and a number of clinical trials are also
ongoing in this area
so
i will spend some time um talking about
the accessibility of the cellular uptake
through the folate receptor we know that
80 percent of the human cancers are
derived from epithelial cells and those
receptors that are restricted to the
apical regions of the cells
can be considered as good targets
because
when drugs are administered parentally
they are not
accessible to normal cells and this is a
big advantage because most of the drugs
that were already available they lack
selectivity especially the
chemotherapeutic drugs they lack
selectivity they show a lot of toxicity
because they not only target
the cancer cells they also target the
normal cells so if you are using a
targeted approach then obviously you
will be able to
take care of
the off target toxicity which is seen in
most cases
so um since receptors are epically
expressed so when uh the drug is
administered verily it is not accessible
to the norm to the normal cells however
when the cells become malignant and the
tight junctions collapse in those cases
the folate receptor becomes
redistributed
on the cell membrane and that is the
reason why it becomes accessible to um
drug uh conjugates which may be uh
administered parentally so this is a big
advantage that uh where you can opt for
targeted drug delivery
so uh three general
strategies have been uh explored uh we
have anti-folate receptor antibody
approach the humanized folate receptor
alpha
antibody drug conjugate approach and the
folic acid smdc approach smdc is the
small molecule drug conjugate approach
so if you look at the molecule of folic
acid
it comprises of three regions you have
the terridine ring you have the para
aminobenzoic
acid
portion of the molecule and you have the
glutamic acid
so it is the pterydine ring which is
primarily involved in the binding to the
folate receptor therefore this part of
the molecule is very much available for
functionalization and can be used
for drug delivery
so a couple of drugs just as examples
so here we have the antibody approach uh
where phallitis map has been
has been tested not only in phase two
but also in phase three and
what has been seen so far is that it did
not meet the primary end point of
improving progression-free survival in
patients
we
there are also some studies which show
the antibody drug conjugate approach and
mirv is one such molecule
one such agent which has been tested
and it is showing some promise but uh
still in phase one and phase two
then we have the folic acid small
molecule drug conjugate approach so full
uh the folic acid conjugates can be used
to deliver the drug payload to the
cancer cells so uh
so what what it
um involves is that folic acid can be
conjugated using um
cleavable bonds and these can carry the
drug payload to the cancer cell once
this
once the folic acid binds to the
receptor it is internalized and the
internal ph of the endosome will result
in the cleavage of the folic acid from
its receptor and also release the drug
payload now once the drug payload is
released the folate receptor recycles
back to the cell membrane and the drug
is
is
delivered at low concentration to the
cancer cells
so that is a very uh interesting
approach and our work is in that
direction however we have made some
changes which i will be talking about
so winter folied is one such molecule
where they have uh tested a vinca
alkaloid and they have tried to
deliver it to cancer cells this molecule
showed a lot of promise
however it is now out of phase 3 trials
so keeping all this
in mind
we looked into the literature and
curcumin which is a well-known
spice which is used in indian food and
it has a lot of medicinal property
we looked into this molecule it's a
wonder molecule because it has
a whole range of
activity
and shows very a lot of promise but
there are some things which have to be
taken care of so it has been associated
with antioxidant anti-inflammatory
anti-cancer antiviral antibacterial
properties
it is also known to chemosensitize many
chemotherapeutic agents such as
5-fluorouracil doxorivisin paclitaxels
platinum etc
the only
drawback of this molecule is its poor
bioavailability and poor absorption so
that is what limits its use
in the clinical setting
so
keeping in mind the multiple targets
that this molecule
is known to modulate
we have designed our own
small molecule drug conjugate
which comprises of folic acid
there is a spacer unit which connects it
to curcumin and finally there is a
cleavable bond
that is
connecting to an anti-cancer drug and we
have used paclitaxel we have used
acid sensitive
cleavable bonds which can cleave at in
the acidic ph of
of the endosome
so i'm going to share some of the
results that preliminary results that
we've got with this triple conjugate
that we have designed uh we have uh
tested our conjugate in
the uh cervical cancers cancer cell
lines like hela and seahaw cell lines
and what we find when we do the mtt
assay of these compounds uh is that our
conjugate is uh working as good as um
the known drug doctor of the sin which
is which is really important because uh
curcumin might be assisting in its um
in um in the drug entering the cancer
cell
the cell proliferation assay also um
when we compare it with curcumin
toxorovicin and with untreated cells we
see that it is showing comparable
activity in at 12 and 24 hours both in
heli and see her cell lines
in order to look at uh
its
ability to enter the cells because it's
a large molecule
is it able to really enter the cells so
we have carried out these
studies where we have seen that our
molecule is able to
enter the cells and this green
fluorescence that you are seeing is of
curcumin which has entered the cancer
cells
after treatment
we have seen it at six hours and 18
hours
using not only curcumin but also
the conjugate and our conjugate
exhibited better
fluorescence as compared to curcumin
which is evident from the figures
we also carried out some
in-vitro cell migration assay using our
conjugate uh doxorubicin and curcumin
and with the controls and what we found
is that in case of the con
the untreated cells uh whereas there was
100 migration of cells but when uh when
we treated with
either of the agents we could see that
cell migration was very much inhibited
um
by using the conjugate specifically
so we've also compared the apoptosis of
our
we have carried out the apoptosis assay
with our conjugate curcumin and oxybusin
in the same cell lines and we find that
this molecule this conjugate in fact uh
shows uh the cells are
more apoptotic
when we treat them with the triple
conjugate
so just to summarize uh
what we have
got so far
is that a conjugate
is uh exhibiting better cytotoxic
activity as compared to curcumin or
oxalism alone uh there is a 30 to 70
percent reduction in cell proliferation
in both hela and csl lines
in our uptick experiment we did see that
the
conjugate could
internalize in the cell and we have seen
it visually that
more concentration of the conjugate or
curcumin which is
could be seen inside the cell which
means that
indeed the conjugate was internalized
inside the cell
the scratch assay
again
showed significant reduction in the
migration rate
as compared to the untreated controls
and the apoptosis assay after treatment
with curcumin doxorivisin um showed that
the apoptosis rate was uh much higher
when
when we
used our conjugate so all these studies
gave us a lot of confidence and now we
are proceeding ahead with more in bible
studies
for our
conjugate and we believe that curcumin
would be
the game changer for this
for this conjugate because it it is
assisting
in the entry of the drug by
chemosensitizing the cell of course most
studies are required for it but
our preliminary results uh indicate that
probably curcumin is assisting and the
drug is able to enter the cell at low
concentration so if uh it is able to
enter at low concentration uh we are
able to also target the cell so we
expect that the off-target toxicity will
be taken care of and at low
concentration we are expecting similar
results as compared to the uh known drug
so um my next part of my presentation is
about the graduate and the post graduate
programs at at my department so we are
we are amity institute of biotechnology
at amity university
and we offer a lot of programs in the
area of biotechnology which includes
b-tech b-tech bioinformatics bsc
programs in biotechnology
bscmsc dual btec dual three continent
programs
and
we also offer bsc biotechnology and b8
courses
and
for our postgraduate programs also we
are offering
the mba biotechnology program msc by
biotechnology bioinformatics mtech
biotechnology and of course our phd
programs we also have some certificate
programs in artificial intelligence we
have masters of technology in
bioinformatics
so it's a big focus in our department
and we have
a large number of students who are
really interested
in all aspects of biotechnology
our institution also offers many uh
opportunities for international
opportunities for students which
include the student exchange programs
the which are offered in france where
students can spend a semester abroad
and complete their studies in a foreign
university we offer study abroad
programs at four or five locations all
over the world and this these are
available to all students ug and pg
students at amity institute of
biotechnology
we also have
a very unique three continent program
now this program
we have
three streams in which we run them the
btec biotech three continent bsc medical
biotech three continent and the bse
honors biotech three continent so in
this the students
complete most of their studies in india
but in the last semester they travel to
uk and u.s for three months each and
finally they get their degree from amity
university
we are also collaborating with many
universities abroad and we are offering
international collaborative programs in
b tech bioinformatics btec biotechnology
international again it is a two plus two
program uh with indiana university and
the bsc honors biotechnology program is
with the university of queensland
australia it's a oneplus 2 program so
students have a plethora of
opportunities if they join the
department and
truly
we believe in creating global citizens
at amity and our students have always
made us proud um
so
and we hope to continue the same in
future
so thank you very much uh thank you for
your patient hearing if there are any
questions i am ready to answer them
thank you very much for this
presentation we do have a few brief
questions here um one of them are
are there any specific techniques
required to synthesize these kinds of
molecules uh he means conjugate
yes so uh conjugation chemistry would
all uh
involve chemical synthesis of the
conjugates but yes it's very important
to
uh characterize whether conjugation
really took place or not so
of course you would be using ir nmr and
you have to use since it's a large
molecule so you may have to
go for malditov to
know the molecular weight of the
molecule so all that is very important
because
just carrying out the synthesis does not
mean that the conjugate got made you
have to characterize it